ronald i've done it i found your
assistant and he's dope
his name is jean-ralphio jean-ralphio
big t mr swanson two things
one it is an absolute honor to meet you
two who is that hot intern chick out
there because honestly
damn uh take a seat right here we go
so jean ralphio you got him right here
leave a message after the beat
why do i want you as my assistant for
starters
access to the illest clubs and that's
just for starters i will work for you
i'll be on you 24 7. i'll be like your
family i'm here when you get here in the
morning sure enough i'll be there
tucking into bed at night don't worry
it's not gay do we have questions
i think our only question is uh when can
you start right now let's do it
thank you for coming in we will talk
cool i feel good about this i know you
can hit me up on facebook any time day
or night you know that right take care
buddy
boom so what do you think of your new
assistant
i want to punch you in the face so bad
right now what will you do me one
final kindness will you pretend to be my
wife for an insurance scam
but then we fall in love for real take
me there
who are you he's here to help us with
the paperwork man is that your real name
yes oh you could do better than that
i'ma help you out right now your name is
angelo angelo thank you so much for
coming out get a thicker tie it looks
weird on you makes your head look like a
fish
secondly i don't know where the
paperwork is but when you find it can
you take care of it for us
we don't have any pens because we're
afraid it's gonna leak in our shirts
lastly i hate the name angelo i'm gonna
switch it up for you right now
your new nickname is
jello shots what do you think about that
j-shot do we have questions
yeah where are we all right ben if you
need anything
one of these models that we pay to hang
around here we'll grab it for you
meantime we're gonna be playing video
games tweeting our high scores
hit it for the shrimp ah okay
rethink that move son
oh my god yeah i know i know i know hey
john ralphio
how's it going it's going good i'm
actually right here for an appointment
getting a brazilian by the way there is
a woman over there that is
unbelievable her name is kim when she
rips it off she smiles and it makes you
feel things
throw my name i get a referral discount
if you don't mind okay
i heard somebody resigned in disgrace my
question to you is how you making that
paper
oh well i've interviewed around uh but
i'm actually about to take a job doing
in-house accounting for an accounting
firm
i almost fell asleep during that
sentence okay let me get this straight
you would be an
accountant for accountants
yeah so at this accounting firm you
would have the boring job
are you nuts this is probably the first
time you've had off since you've been
kid president true or false
true why don't you use that time and go
after one of your passions
like model trains or like toy gandolfs
or something
oh why you jump straight to model trains
i mean
it's accurate i'm gonna tell you
something that i once heard from a very
very smart woman named kim the lady
who waxes you she told me if you don't
love what you do
then why do it then she ripped the hair
from my b-hole
time to start a casino in a tajikistan
oh my god you're john ralphio's dad
you're the one that's trying to put me
out of business well look at that mr
haverford you tracked me down
looks like your detective skills are a
lot better than your tween
high-end fashion rental skills and chris
can we have the room please
no you certainly cannot dr saperstein
why are you doing this what did i ever
do to you you know exactly why i'm doing
this
you destroyed my family first you
screwed my son out of your business
and then you stole my daughter's
virginity
[Laughter]
wait you're serious deadly serious
according to my daughter you broke her
heart
then you smashed up her bmw i had to buy
her a new one so she could drive to
divinity school
let me tell you something mister you
attack a saperstein
you face my wrath be so sure about this
tiny tom
that i will crush you like the bug you
are
ah and there it is the heartbeat
hold up my dad said that yeah john
ralphio
he told me that i had screwed you out of
my business
so he was gonna screw me back any idea
why he'd believe such a thing that is so
weird that is so oh you know what
honestly not i'm thinking about it this
may be it i actually told him that
rent-a-swag was my idea
and that you had stole it from me why
would you say that
because my dad is always riding me for
never having a job and i just didn't
want to show that i blew it again
oh and i don't know if this is relevant
but i told him that you made me sign up
for a bunch of credit cards and then
max them out by buying illegal white
jaguar fur coat oh
that's probably not relevant it's not
relevant though i don't know
all that's lying about me stops now
this is my life please one of you has to
tell him the truth
got it oh you got me
oh okay fine you know what i'm gonna do
the unthinkable
i'm gonna have a short honest
conversation with my father
thank you thank you all for coming
and let me just say how truly deeply
true it is
to be standing in this dope-ass
conference room and
dressing a group of people in a business
meeting it's really a dream come true
uh right now i want to turn the floor
over to john ralphio who has something
to say
tom lawyer guy daddy
tom did not screw me out of the company
he gave me every opportunity to jump in
at the ground floor and i said no not
because
i thought it was a bad idea but because
and this is very
important i really didn't care about
what was happening
so why exactly did you lie when i asked
you what had happened
daddy did daddy well i lie to you all
the time all those math camps i said i
went to
i don't even know what a math camp is so
all those postcards that you sent me all
those trophies that you'd won
trophies i bought
i also have something to say
i have done nothing wrong ever
in my life i know this
and i love you i love you too daddy
mommy please
my money dr saperstein your son
is my best friend yeah he's like a
brother to me but he's a disaster
and your daughter seriously needs to be
locked up in some sort of insane asylum
um
on an island oh in space
these two have been huge disappointments
to me
come on you love us tell me you love us
and then admit
this guy looks like beaker from the
muppets
but seriously what are we doing here why
are we
here no
now you know the truth will you back off
no i will not stop
yes this all started as vengeance for my
children
but the company is making money now why
would i back off just cause these nincom
poops lie to me all the time
no i'm not gonna back off i'm gonna
continue
and i'm gonna crush you all right
you too are you in for dinner tomorrow
night yes
call me a kiss got it
i love you daddy i love you you know
what i loved
[Applause]
[Music]
i have an amazing investment idea for
you condoms
with pictures on them good smart i think
you made my decision
take care welcome mr saperstein thank
you so much i will just show you to your
cubicle i can't i bet it's a big one huh
barney ah
the uh temp agency said that you are
fluent with quickbooks pro correct all
right yeah we should cover that you see
my resume might not actually be accurate
right so i have no idea what you're
talking about
don't know what quickbooks are you don't
have any accounting experience no no no
barney come on
but you don't have to be an accountant
to know that this girl
is a 10. yeah what up diaz you come here
often
to my job ooh mouth on her also shut it
is this the new temp who's supposed to
help me with the spreadsheets
i'm gonna talk about spreading your
sheets when we go back to my place and i
will rock
your you're fired that makes sense so i
just go out the same way i came in oh
hold up i will do john mayer again
daddy someone set a fire in your car
because you took too long
and i got bored money please
oh no no there's no money oh
my bad no problem that's fine um
i'll just destroy this office oh hey
hmm
give her some money it's easier tommy t
you just missed the craziest of crazies
clubs
girls dancing naked mom argument
police fleeing the seed hiding in a
dumpster coming here
crashing on your couch for a week cause
technically i'm homeless
you